didier combo chercheur associé à
l'institut des amériques et docteur en
civilisation américaine
les combos bonjour et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france alors tout d'abord s'agit-il
d'une insurrection comme l'a qualifié
joe biden le nouveau président des états
unis où un coup d'état raté selon vous
quel regard portez vous sur les
événements que l'on a pu vivre hier soir
bonjour mais écoutez si si c'était si
c'était un coup d'état il était en tout
cas très mal préparée
c'est pas exactement de cette manière là
qu'on fait un coup d'état c'était plutôt
une manifestation qui a key qui a un peu
dégénéré puisqu'il ya eu quand même
quatre personnes tuées
mais c'était une manifestation on peut
pas dire que que donald trump ce soit on
paie remparts et d'aider des commandes
du pouvoir qui lui permettait de rester
en place donc la confirmation de bail
donne à d'ailleurs bien du lieu de la
trump ya un petit peu quand même nourrit
cette violence puisqu'il avait appelé à
manifester à washington
dès hier soir d'ailleurs il ya plusieurs
voies qui ont commencé à s'élever qui
demande à mike pence le vice président
des états unis de déclencher le 25e
amendement de la constitution pour
destituer donald trump on sait qu'il ne
reste que 13 jours au président sortant
est ce que vous pensez que cela est
possible
celle également possible ça sera pas
forcément facile étant donné le peu de
temps le peu de temps qui reste c'est
une procédure qui est assez lourd
puisqu'il n'est nécessaire peut pas être
le vice-président peine tous calais qui
demandent cette cette invalidation en
quelque sorte du président il faut qu'il
y ait avec lui des membres du des
membres du gouvernement qui s'associe à
lui pour cela et il faut qu'il y ait un
vote du congrès et si preuve décidé de
rester en place il faudrait qu'il y ait
un vote au congrès à la majorité
qualifiée donc c'est quand même une
procédure qui paraît très compliqué
étant donné le peu de temps qui reste
maintenant jusqu'au 20 janvier
mais ce qui effectivement prêts hors
normes dans cette situation c'est que
cette manifestation de l'été quand même
alors peut-être pas à l'instigation de
20 39 cas de mal qu'un plan encourager
et à bien tardé à intervenir lorsque les
des manifestants se sont introduits dans
le capital car des travaux qui pour la
première fois on peut le dire a reconnu
sa défaite aujourd'hui il a promis une
des sites une transition pardon ordonnée
vous pensez qu'il va tenir sa promesse
ou est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à des
scènes similaires dans les prochains
jours du moins j'espère
jusqu'au 20 janvier on peut se le
demander parce que on sais pas jusqu'à
quel point
donald trump contrôler ces manifestants
ces manifestations elles sont aussi
organisés sur internet donc trump n'est
pas un complètement je pense en contrôle
tout ça ils l'encouragent
mais est ce qu'il en est véritablement
l'instigateur ça n'est pas sûr donc
est-ce qu'ils arriveront à calmer c'est
tout parce qu'il a la volonté de le
faire d'abord et puis est-ce qu'il
arrive à les calmer avant on compense en
particulier évidemment à la cérémonie
d'investiture où il peut y avoir
éventuellement que les manifestations
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire que
joe biden ça aurait renforcé qu'il
arrive à la maison blanche
voilà plutôt à l'aise après justement
ces événements qui ont montré cette
division des états unis jamais on
n'avait vu des images comme celles ci là
bas alors plutôt à l'aise c'est quand
même un bien grand mot parce que une
proportion importante des américains
pensent que les élections ont été
truquées
même s'il n'y a jamais eu roewe de
malversations qui auraient pu tirer plus
de fraudes qui auraient pu permettre de
faire élire il donne à la place d'autres
noms on peut pas dire qu'il est anti ans
là sa situation est anormale
mais il en sort renforcée en ce sens que
une fière comme d'ailleurs dans d'autres
occasions auparavant il a une stature
présidentielle il est apparu à la
télévision alors que tout président en
titre de mauvaises silencieux donc dans
cette motion la nuit ils en sont
renforcés dubaï bonn aussi enfin le camp
démocrate surtout qui après maintenant
possession va dire du congrès après le
sénat qui a penché justement du côté du
camp des démocrates
cela va-t-il changer quelque chose dans
la politique
américaine bah oui parce que le set
c'était la grande question de savoir si
le sénat allait alors l'équipe a
vraiment une époque faste mais il y a
maintenant le 50 sénateurs républicains
et 50 sénateurs démocrates et nice et
donc à disposer d'un voile alice qui
aura donc c'était effectivement un des
grands enjeux
ces jours derniers et cela va permettre
à l'administration maiden de mettre sa
politique en place facilement que si les
républicains avaient été majoritaire
c'est très important pour la nomination
des membres du cabinet c'est important
pour la nomination des juges dans le
fédéral c'est fédéral donc effectivement
là bas il donne va avoir effectivement
les rênes marrant hein
alors on l'a dit les américains vont
tourner la page de donald trump
d'ici quelques jours que peut-on retenir
justement de son mandat est ce que les
images d'hier soir résume ces quatre ans
de présidence n'ont pas tout à fait
parce que prendra quand même tenu ses
promesses les promesses qu'il avait fait
en 2016 alors il n'a pas pu toutes les
tenir milan est très bien c'est pas mon
avis il a fait une réforme des impôts
il a même fait une réforme de la justice
pénale conclut sociaux sont en base
n'est pas à l'image ce chaos que l'on
voit là et il et de son attitude à la
chain dû à la fin du mandat en fait ses
preuves a été à la fois servi quand sa
personnalité qui lui a certainement qui
n'a certainement aidé à être élu mais il
n'a pas su endosser des habits de
président en quelque sorte il a pas su
investir la fonction de président et sa
sortie de scène en tant que président
est tout de même un petit peu piteuse
merci beaucoup d'idées qu'on vous
d'avoir réagi avec nous ce matin je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur associé
à l'institut des amériques et docteur en
civilisation américaine